400 000 people were there yeah dude it's
it's crazy but you know what it made me
realize a lot of things one
i think f1 is going to take a long time
for it to blow up here because
the way they handle the media is so bad
they had like that dude martin brundle
try to interview megan the stallion like
on the track
she clearly wasn't briefed that she's
gonna get an interview so he just looks
like this random british guy like
running up to her and
he runs up he's like
megan megan her security's like the [ __ ]
like tries to push him away and she like
hits her security she's like let him you
know
i'm from the bbc yeah no literally he's
got sky sports on his [ __ ] it's like
major broadcast
and martin is already known for asking
like dumb ass questions he like
bro he could have like serena williams
standing there that's the other thing
that f1 does they take these big
celebrities and just insert them in
awkward situations
like it'll be the race has just finished
finished they're going to do the podium
and then they'll be like and serena
williams
serena williams what
she's just here
she'll just like then it'll be like do
you like tennis should be like uh yes
did you enjoy the race yes
lando how'd you feel about today and
then she'll just stand there while so
you know it's just like they just don't
do that [ __ ] right
so
martin as he's like chasing down megan
he goes
do you have a rap prepared for us today
just like
that's horrible
dog that's the first thing in a while
that made me cringe bad i was like ah
and then
someone in her like posse
he's like this
you know blond-haired dude he he looks
like one like a music person he's got
like bleach blonde hair it's like he's
got like a karen cut it's like around
his face green pants
three buttons open someone in megan's
crew yeah okay
he walks by and he pushes martin out of
the way and he goes
you can't do that
like referring to the question he just
asked and then he hits him with the most
british [ __ ] i've ever heard he's like
well yes i can because i just did and
then he walks away ah yes did you see
all this go down no i saw this after
okay like there's a recording of it yeah
yeah yeah okay that's what i'm saying i
would play it but we'll get like got you
got you got you okay you know yeah we'll
be the one with our ass and balls in the
air yeah if i open the door like no
i think the highlight of it was uh this
dude checko he's the second driver for
red bull
his like water tank went out after the
first lap so he did like lit like an
hour of racing in the texas heat with no
[ __ ] water oh jesus christ yeah
he was like oh this is the hardest race
of my entire life
uh he was saying like if something
failed like on the car he's like i
wouldn't have had the strength to like
control it i just like would have gone
with the car like he's just barely
hanging on for the whole race
he gets out
post race interview
it's like the second interview he does
after placing third in the race they're
like checko
how you feeling um
i had diarrhea this morning
it like wasn't really related
everyone's like that goddamn text
message yeah
[Laughter]
everyone was like damn bro what a chad
how you feeling after this race brother
you did an amazing job i had diarrhea
speaking of which did you have barbecue
no so what come on bro
i'm sorry i'm yapping i know but like
these red bull [ __ ] like
they
just go
in it's like they go till two in the
morning and they're smiling like all the
way through and they get up at six and
like go to the track they start drinking
some more
and they just so i had just like
you know i had survival food throughout
you know damn dude yeah
i know i'm sorry i didn't tell you i
made a brisket did i did i tell you that
i mean i assume i tried to make a
brisket last weekend oh no not last week
in the weekend before oh
i [ __ ] that thing up royally
oh my god they just come out like
looking totally opposite it's like
salami you're like yeah yeah basically
honestly
seriously
this [ __ ] came out and it was just black
and like it dude it was like it was like
chewing on a leather shoe
unbelievable
all these youtube videos i watch all the
comments are like oh i was so scared to
try a brisket i was so scared to try a
[ __ ]
how hard could this possibly be and so i
go and buy one and i realize okay people
are scared because it's [ __ ]
expensive things 150 bucks for a full
brisket
right la prices granted but still yeah
that's like the most expensive
i mean that's like the you know yeah
wagyu stakes there that are like less
than that yeah because it's a big cut of
meat yeah
and i i guess it's really easy to [ __ ]
up and so people are scared to do it i'm
like [ __ ] you guys like just how hard
could this possibly be right and i just
basically i watched the wrong youtube
tutorial on how to do it i watched a
[ __ ] i did like a [ __ ] ton of research
before because i didn't want to [ __ ] it
up you just chuck it on oh okay but you
have to monitor the temperature the
whole way through so basically what i
did is i i just kind of i was watching
this tutorial it was the official
traeger youtube channel yeah how to cook
a brisket and i followed their ribs
tutorial before and it worked perfectly
so i was like okay this one should work
too right yeah
their editor put in a title card that
said six hours the guy never said
six hours
he said monitor the temperature i looked
at that title card and i was like okay
i'm good for six hours and then i can
check the temperature oh
i come out it was six hours you know to
cook a brisket everyone says 12 hours
okay six hours it was done
you just saw spongebob shoes in there
you're like
[Laughter]
the [ __ ]
and i was all like i just took it out
and i tried biting one of like the burnt
ends and it was just
burnt end yeah yeah like in the in the
true sense of that [ __ ] gave me cancer
for sure
just black
i'm gonna try it again this weekend
you're thinking about all those comments
you're putting that [ __ ] on yeah you
[ __ ] yeah exactly how hard could this
be
damn
well
i hope you i hope you're successful yeah
did you did you do the updating people
next week
did you do like the prideful thing where
you just you sat there and you ate it
just cause you spent the money and i
tried to i tried to like do something
with it i i shredded it a little bit i
mix it with some barbecue sauce to give
it a little bit of moisture
nothing dude
horrible damn
literally eating like paper shredder
yeah yeah [ __ ] it was bad anyways no i'm
i'm bummed i didn't get to
try any
like you know spots out there but they
took us to a few places that tasted
insane it was [ __ ] up we went one
place where they had like a ton of
flatbreads
and i'm like
why do restaurants it's pizza
stop playing it's pizza
not flatbread
it's
flatbread yeah flatbread is pizza yeah
that's fair different bread though i
think it is difficult it's not the whole
point yeah yeah yeah i mean but it's
pizza yeah that's fair no it's not for
kasha it's like super thin usually
but it's pizza it's pizza yeah like
however they want to say what the
origins are that [ __ ] is pizza man
like i hate
i don't know hey but i was like laughing
because all this food started coming out
they had like this wagyu
uh cheeseburger you know and they're
trying to make it all fancy i'm like
this is [ __ ] shake shack yeah like
you have pizza shake shack i know you
have chicken tenders back there you're
going to try to tell me there's
something else yeah
i don't know it was just funny to me
there's a wagyu place i was in san diego
this weekend and there's a wagyu place
there and it's called swagu
i was like that [ __ ] slaps
definitely an sdsu student i started
that place
bro let's call it swagu
yeah so i was like in my third year i'm
like i don't want to do this [ __ ] and i
have wagyu for the first time i'm like
this would be so
good like if you could have it all the
time yeah
and so i look at like wagyu places and
then you know i'm just kind of like
[ __ ] up one night and i'm like
yo let's get some swag you and then it
hit me
yo this should be a restaurant
so now we're here and we have 44
locations i remember the first time i
said it first time i actually coined it
all my boys i was at the frat house and
all my boys were like that's the sickest
word i've ever heard
because it combines both swag and wagyu
and i love both those things literally
my boy came up with swag you and i'm
like you're literally a renaissance man
because like everyone thinks the word
swag like fell off but it didn't and
like he fully brought it back and like
that [ __ ] is just so sick yeah
so how'd it taste did you go no i didn't
go
i have no idea